hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
deep clip predicting the effect of
mutations on protein rna binding with
deep learning
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
gen script to learn more visit
genscript.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
thomas doctor
molecular biologist department of
biochemistry and molecular biology
university of southern denmark thomas
you may now begin your presentation
okay welcome and uh thank you for
joining this webinar where
i'm going to present our tool called
deep clip
and uh ways of using it to uh to analyze
and predict the effect of mutations
that might affect protein rna binding
so starting
so starting right from the beginning uh
the central doctrine of molecular
biology we produce
proteins from dna via irony
and of course rna is uh not just a naked
rna
as in this picture but it is is uh often
in a complex with a lot of rna binding
proteins
so if you look at this figure for
instance we can see that rna is
transcribed
from dna and then undergoes a lot of
processing
and binding a lot of these rna binding
proteins some of them
are generally binding to rna and others
have more specific sequences that they
bind
if you go right to the top for looking
at transcription
we can see that there's a lot of
proteins involved in that
in our group we focus on spicing and
splicing is a is the removal of introns
and
the ligation of exons into a mature
mrna that also contains a five prime cap
and the three-pound poly a
so that process is regulated by a number
of of different factors of course the
spliceosome is this multi
uh megadalton complex of many
different molecules both proteins and
rnas
and specifically the use nodes recognize
the spice sites that
specifically delineate the beginning and
end of
introns and exons but the
regulation of the use of these exons
whether they're included in the
transcript or not
is often regulated by splicing factors
which are rna binding proteins
and they bind to these enhancer elements
and silencing elements and if they're in
exons we call them exotic splicing
enhancers for instance
for an enhancer and an exotic splicing
silencer
uh for for an instant for a silencer and
the balance between those
uh is is uh is uh tightly regulating
uh whether these exons are included or
not and sometimes it's a very delicate
balance
and of course this allows the cell to
produce multiple different variants
of the same protein via different
transcripts for you
so if we're looking at an exon here we
can see that it might be included in
some
cases or it might be skipped they can
also be mutually exclusive exons or
there could be alternative spice sites
or simply a retention of an intron
so in normal cells or in normal
conditions the axon might be included
and producing
a normal transcript that result results
in a normal protein
but if there is a mutation that might
affect these
enhancer elements and affect the binding
to their respective rna binding proteins
that could result in a misproduction of
a
of us of a transcript that does not
contain the axon
and that can result in dysfunctional
proteins or degradation of the
transcript
via nmd so those mutations that
may not even disrupt the reading frame
and may not change the amino acids
because they disrupt spicing they can
have a potentially strong deleterious
effect and cause disease
we can also have mutations in the
introns uh and sometimes they can
activate what is known as a pseudoexon
or a cryptic axon
that is part of the entrone which has
a very high similarity to an exon but is
not normally included
we might have a mutation that then
creates or
destroys uh an rna binding
uh motif on a binding protein motive and
that results in activation of the pseudo
x and that might be included in this
in this transcript disrupting the normal
function
so if we go back here and view in this
slide here you can see that these are
there's a number of different elements
that
all affect spicing of an exon so
in all of these motifs that bind rna
binding proteins
you will have fairly uh fairly motive
specific
proteins that recognize specific sites
and mutation is the
in these taken disruptive binding or so
either by increasing it or discrete
decreasing it
uh to a kind of uh
apparent uh function in essentially
but rna binding proteins they're also
depending a lot on the context
so some of these motives might be in
close proximity to each other
and so they're also in competition with
each other uh so they're highly dynamic
and simply having a motive does not
necessarily mean that this is a
functional binding site
and that is a it's a complication
in predicting whether a motive binds to
a particular protein or not
if we go in and look what is the normal
variation in the human genome
uh then from the thousand genomes
project we know that there are tens of
thousands of
variants in in exons and many of them
are synonymous so they don't really
change the amino acids
but all of them might change pricing we
also have
uh more than one and a half million of
these intronic variants on average
and essentially every one of them has
some small chance of activating or
or just disrupting spicing so all of
these
are really uh
part of what makes us different so they
can cause variation
but they can also cause disease and of
course there are so many we cannot
functionally test everyone so so we do
need in silicon tools
these mutations and variations they also
act together
so so this is a case of uh of a deceased
major in here
at position 362 in the academ gene
uh where a patient mutation uh changing
the c
the natural c to a t disrupts uh
enhancer element and
causes excellent skipping so here we've
used a
mini gene uh and introduced or ordered
these
mutations so that we can test their
function
so if you look in this lower picture
here we've done
with transfected cells with amino gene
and
purified rna and and done an rt-pcr
so we and then separate it on an acura's
gel so we can separate the long band
which contains the axons
from the uh the exon from the lower band
which does not
so in the first lane we have the wild
type
uh where we see inclusion of the exon
and also some skipping this is sometimes
the case in many genes that you have
a little bit different spicing from the
wild type and then we're going to have
the disease variant 362t we get
predominant skipping and almost no
inclusion and actually this is what
causes the
the phenotype the deceased phenotype in
this case
there is an amino acid change but it
doesn't it doesn't have a dramatic fact
effect on the enzyme activity so it is
the skipping of the axon that causes the
enzyme deficiency but there is also a
normal
uh polymorphism a normal snip located at
position 351
so normally there is an a and in this
case
the snip is a c this is a completely
silent
mutation or variant that does not change
the amino acid and it also does not
change splicing
but when you have both the normal
you have the variant in the c
then if you have a introduction of the
disease causing a variation you actually
have protection from the sea here
so uh the ultimate outcome
of these snips are depending on which
context they're sitting in
so we cannot just analyze each of
each of them individually uh so
this just creates an even bigger problem
of understanding
uh the particular functions of these
snips
because then we have a number of
different variations
so so having in silico predictions tools
to to analyze these
are really essential
so this is not a new problem of course
but it's a difficult problem uh in the
past
uh we've used position weight matrices
such as
uh ese finder where we
can analyze the motive directly and
that means that we're looking at each
base individually so in those motif
the bases are independent from each
other so
having a single base change only affects
that particular base
there's no context modeling another
method is to simply have database
lookups so we know some of those motives
or we have some statistical modeling
of motives that might be enriched in
exons versus
introns and these rescue easy and fast
css
are examples of that more recent years
there's also been machine learning
methods
such as support vector machines and one
of those as well
is graphprod which introduced the
modeling of structure
as well so the graphbot has a step where
you input very large long sequences
and spend a long time modelling the
structure and then that structure is
part of what
is uh is giving the ultimate prediction
in the india in the end there's also
neural networks uh
deepine was the first and deepine works
by having many many different motives
for
essentially for for the same protein so
so instead of having just one position
make weight matrices
it has a different it has a number of
different motives and features that are
recognized
another case or example is idps
which works a little bit uh like deep
bind and it
recognizes motives but it also has a
structure modeling step
uh with a different tool similar to
graph products so you
input both your sequence and then you
need to run a structure more
modeling and and use that as an input as
well
so these existing tools
are all in some way lacking in features
when we were using them in particular
the the context modeling is
is focused on structure and many rna
binding proteins are depending on
certain structures
but that's not the only type of context
that could affect binding
it could be that they act in in concert
so that
having multiple motives or having
different types of protein binding and
having a synergy
is actually increasing that binding
strength
it could also be that some proteins bind
specifically near five points by site
so that that would be a type of context
that was important
another problem with having structure
prediction is that
it requires long sequences so if your
model
is depending on this structure you
really have uh
don't have as high efficiency when
you're predicting on on shoulder
structure
where your structure modeling doesn't
really work
and then this structure prediction is
itself an encyclical step
so it's not error proof and it's it's
noisy so you're also
introducing noise in some way into the
system
and there is also generally a lag of
individual
base scores so in the motive you
if you have a position weight matrix it
typically has a length of six or seven
or eight
then you get a score for those eight
bases
and uh you don't really know if you
change your base
uh it it might change that particular
motive but it might also result in
that you have a little bit of shift of a
motive so you need to do a lot of
different
comparison and and scoring with these
position weight matrices
um so that's one way that you can kind
of get individual basis but it takes a
long time and it's not
it's not straightforward and if you have
uh these machine learning models and
neural networks you often get
just a single prediction score so you
can
actually then uh introduce invitation
on each base all possible mutations
but of course that greatly increases the
number of predictions that you need to
run and you also need to manually
analyze them or at least
at least have the uh the capability of
doing that
and there's also not a support of
variable length input for all of these
tools so so some of them are require
fixed length input
and some of them do allow variable
length input but
but we don't we sort of lack a tool that
combines all of these so so that's why
we designed d-clip
so we designed it to have uh arbitrary
context modeling where we don't really
tell
uh the models which kind of contacts
that we're looking for
but we have a model or a design of the
neural network
that allows a certain level of context
modeling
and that also means that we don't need
any extra tools to predict structure
so we just need the sequence and we
introduced the a binding profile so that
the overall result of the analysis is
not just a single score
but it's a it's an individual base score
as a binding profile
and because we have these binding
profiles we can also provide
variable length input and variable
length
it does affect the overall prediction
score
but i'll show later how the binding
profile actually allows us to still
examine
quite fairly different lengths of input
so d-flip is a neural network and and
just briefly
to explain neural networks they are
these
nodes in in different layers that are
all interconnected
so usually we have an input layer and
all of those inputs are then fed into
the network
where there is a number of different
hidden layers that we don't really see
and they are connected so that they get
input from the previous layer and then
they output something to the next layer
and ultimately we have an output layer
that can be many
nodes but it can also just be a single
node with a range
in values that you're interested in so
this is a very general approach
so uh as you can see here on the left
the prototype
uh multi-layer perceptron this is this
is this kind of network with just a
single hidden layer
in deep clip we also use something
called convolutional nail networks
and they are they have fewer connections
so that
the nodes in the uh see the
convolutional layer
they are only connected to some of the
inputs so for instance here
each node is connected to two of the
inputs
and sort of in a sliding window so so we
move one step forward so the next node
is
connected to to uh uh the next two
nodes uh the of the input and all of
these nodes in the under the
convolutional layer they share
parameters so so what really happens is
that here we can
identify local features and local
patterns so this is how we extract
motifs of the rna binding profile or rna
binding proteins
we also use a type of network that's
called a recurrent neural network
and what's unique about this is that not
only are the nodes connected
to the input but they're also connected
to themselves and the other nodes in the
layer
we then use a different type or
variation called long short term memory
that has multiple parameters inside the
nodes that allow
it to to be activated after certain
patterns so
they can forget things and they can uh
just choose when to to to become
activated
so it resembles in some ways a type of
memory
so when we combine all these things we
have the overall deep flip
architecture where we have input we then
encode it into
a numeric string so that we can process
this with these uh
equations that a neural network
essentially is
we have then the convolutional layers
and then we use a type of enhancement
called the
winnetex alt so we have a number of
different
sizes of these convolutions so different
filter sizes different motif sizes
essentially
and for each of them we enhance just one
part of the sequence
we then combine all of the different
enhanced sequences
with the original sequence and then we
feed that into our
lstm layer so this long short term
memory layer
where we are able to model context we
then use something called a
bi-directional
layer but it's really just two different
lstm layer where one layer is fed
the input from the forward direction and
the other layer is fat the input from
the reverse
and that's because these memories they
they only work
they can remember the past but they
can't predict the future
so they remember what the sequence was
before
so in order to get context modeling in
both direction we need to feed in the
sequence in both direction
after that we then combine the two and
then we sum them into a binding profile
and that is the primary result
of of deep flip we can then squash
with the output layer this binding
profile into a single prediction score
and that's what we use when we train
then we only use the prediction score
and not the binding profile so once
we've trained the model
we can then extract the motifs from the
convolutional layers
and here you can see that we have some
uag
binding protein so it does really
seem to recognize some patterns in in
the data
when we run a prediction we can then
extract the binding profile
and we can extract the overall
prediction score
so you can see that the binding profile
it has this wavy or curvy
uh pattern where it sort of highlights
uh
motive uh or sequence patterns that are
sort of contributing positively or
negatively
to the prediction score so if there is a
lot of negative scores then it's
producing a low prediction score if
there's a lot of positive is producing a
high
and we call it a binding profile but
it's it's
also a profile of which areas of the
sequence seem to have a positive
contribution to binding
so we call this deep clip because we're
using deep learning with several layers
in the neural networks
and then we're using clip data to to
train the model so
so clip is cross linking and
immunoprecipitation
and it's a number of different
techniques with the variations on the
same principle
uh where you can identify specific
location of protein binding in the
genome
so in this experiment we irradiate cells
cells with the uv light and that induces
crosslinking
of the rna binding protein to the rna
preferentially at the site of binding or
hopefully we then
degrade the rna so we get fragments of
rna that are shorter
and ideally only bind one protein we can
then use a specific antibody
to immunoprecipitate the the
complexes with a specific protein of
interest
and their cross-linked rna so then we
can purify these
complexes and sequence them on these
novel massively parallel sequencing
instruments and then all of those
sequences we can map to the genome and
then identify as binding site
by looking at where there is a high
coverage
so for deep clip once we have these
binding sites we
then regard them as positive binding
sites of course there will be false
positive in this data set
and there will also be many positive
binding sites that were not picked up on
the experiment
but for for a simplification purpose we
assigned that
as a positive binding site then in order
to have a suitable negative background
uh we could either shuffle that sequence
or just pick a sequence at random
but we've selected to shuffle this the
peaks that are in the gene and then pick
uh the same size distribution peaks uh
in the same gene so essentially for each
peak in a gene
we move it to a random location within
the same gene
we then check that it doesn't overlap
any of the other peaks that we're using
in that
both positive and negative and then we
we extract that sequence so that
we define that as a negative background
and that hopefully produces a background
that is
as realistic as possible of course we
might have false negatives we might have
a
random location where this protein also
binds
but in most cases it works fairly well
so once we have these two we can input
them into deep clip
and deep fib will then partition them
into
a training data set and a validation
data set and a test data set
so in this way we can during training we
can validate if we are doing well
and then finally when we're done
training we can test the model on this
final test set so
if we want to compare deep clip to other
tools
the best way is to do this tenfold cross
validation where we simply repeat this
10
times and then we make sure that each of
these 10
partitions is used exactly once as a
training
assorted test set exactly once as a
validation and then eight times as a
training
uh so in that way we have ten models
where uh
each model has not seen 10 of the data
so we can have a prediction on the full
uh
data set uh without having uh
tests uh input that was already seen by
the model
because whenever you're training a model
when if you predict on the same type of
data
it will have a very high score without
being as useful in in real world
we then measure this performance with
something called an area under the
rock curve this receiver operator curve
and the idea
here is that if you get two sequences
um one is uh is a negative one is a
positive what is your
chance of guessing correctly so so if we
look at the area under this curve
we have a 90 uh score or 0.9 if you're
measuring just
from series of one and that means that
we have a 90 chance of guessing
correctly
uh and that's and that's uh that's good
uh if in the
perfect world this classifier would be
completely up in the left corner and it
would have an area under the curve of
a 100 or one depending on how you're
seeing it
so if you have a very bad model it will
follow this dotted line in the middle
and that just means that it's
the model is no better than flipping a
coin so we want to be up in the
in the upper left corner so in order to
compare d clip to the existing tools
we use this benchmark data set
introduced by the graph
paper where there is a number of
different clip sets where all of these
tools have already produced data
of this kind so we then compared deep
clips performance
and we compared it both to graphpod
which does have a binding profile
but it's more something that you can
produce with the model in addition to
the predictions cause
so the prediction and score is not
itself a a
derived directly from the binding
profile but it does produce a binding
profile but
when we compare deep flip with graph but
we can see that we have
a significant improvement in the
performance
so in most cases deep clip will provide
a
a better uh prediction and correlation
than graph product if we compare uh with
other tools that do not have binding
profiles that just have
a single score uh some of them are
improved compared to graph
but in in in our in this
benchmark we can see that for each of
them deeply pass
sometimes a small but statistically
significant higher performance
if we look if we look at the kind of
biases
that affect these for instance we can
see that there are multiple different
uh clip methods so there's hits clip
iclip and parklip
so does that method itself affect the
the model performance and and at least
from this data set there is not
a statistically significantly different
the difference between the methods but
some of them are
are quite small they're only a handful
of hitch clip and icloud datasets
most of them are partly if we look at
the number of inputs
there's only a very weak and
non-significant correlation
uh you might might assume that the the
more input that you have the better the
model will be
but more input also might not be more
stringent input so
so there might be the same level of
noise
in in the system uh input length also
does not uh
affect but if it does it's it's it's a
it's a weak
correlation of sorts
if we look at the sequence content then
we can see that there is a statistically
uh significant negative correlation with
the gc percentages and and positive for
the u fraction the u percentage
and that's probably because clip
experiments are known to be affected
uh by this bias because you
cross links more efficiently so there is
the tendency
that if you do find a binding site then
that motive will be very close to
a bunch of views and those were to use
that crosslinked
so so the training data is biased
in that regard if we look at the other
bases a c and g
we can see uh that at least g is also
negatively so so we have fewer g's
and so they have been uh the
the high u fraction is at the cost of a
lower g
so so does that affect models and and uh
yes uh some models uh seem to be more
they seem to recognize a clip side as
much as they recognize the protein side
so for instance here we have the pom2
model
and when we use the positive pump 2 and
then the positive from a different data
set the quaker
um we can see that yes the pump 2 model
does predict high scores for the
positive binding size
but also there is also a tendency to
predict high scores for the quaker size
whereas if we use the quaker model train
on quagga and negative background for
quaker
we can see that it separates these two
pump 2 and quaker
data sets quite nicely so what if we
look at the motives that these models
found
then we can see that the pontoon model
actually identifies the known pun2 motif
uh just like the quaker model identifies
the the known
quaker motif but they also both have
these
uh cau rich motives uh that that is part
of the model so that might be
apocalypse signature um or in some
manner
that is affecting the pontoon model more
so so is this
uh this is a problem not just for deep
clip but also the other tools because
this is a bias in the training
data and it's in sort of incorporated
into that benchmark data set
but in deep clip we also have the
binding profiles and the binding
profiles contain
much more information because it's not
just a single score
so in d-clip we allow people to produce
binding profiles in you know what we
call a long prediction mode where we
simply have a sliding window
and then uh take the central binding
profile score of each
nucleotide so then we can produce this
binding profile across this
transcript jmj d1c transcript
which is almost 9 kb so 9000 base pair
long
and of course having such a long binding
profile it kind of looks like a noise
recording
with a lot of noise in um so
we then identify binding sites for both
palm two and quaker
as having this uh sliding window where
at least nine nucleotides must have at
least
an average score on the binding profile
greater than 0.3
so we can then map to this transcript
which is known to bind both quaker and
pump two sides
so in the transcript structure uh in the
cartoon
we have uh in in in a line we have the
five prime utr
and then in the box we have the reading
frame and then in the line again we have
the three prime util
on top of that we've mapped the
experimentally identified
binding site quaker sites in blue and
and palm two sides in red
and then we predicted uh using the
binding profiles and this
sliding window algorithm uh likely
binding sites for both pum2 and quaker
so you can see uh here on the park clip
you we have a number
of uh pump two predicted binding sites
from the deep clip model
based on this graph data set and and
several of them they overlap these
experimentally validated binding site
and none of them overlap any of the
quaker sites on the other other hand
the quaker model has a predicted binding
site where one of them is
is overlapping the experimentally
identified and
one of them is very close to we also
made
uh palm two models and quake two
sorry quaker models from the encode
dataset eclipse from the k562
cell line and here we've got uh more
upon two prediction
uh or binding sites uh but um
they also tend to be mostly in the three
prime utr
and overlap with the uh with the known
binding sites
so so even when we have these biases in
the training data
that do really affect the overall
binding or overall prediction score
by having these binding profiles we can
actually mitigate some of that bias
so so the models are useful even though
when they are biased
okay so on the benchmark data set we
didn't have our own provided backgrounds
so in order to test
this way of constructing the background
is is
also useful we uh created these new
models
uh of asian ipa1 and srsf1 and
hn iron pa1 is a classic inhibitor of
splicing
and uh inhibits inclusion of exons
whereas slsf1
is a classic splicing activator and
promotes inclusion
so those those are often involved in
regulating splicing and and
there are many cases of mutations
affecting binding of these that cause x
on skipping
so here we uh have the motips of h and
in va one and
at the top and also the the rock curve
so you can see that we have fairly
robust
uh performance of this model across the
different uh
data sets we then ex we then pick out
the best performing one
uh and produce the motives from that and
use that and
similarly for sis of one where we used
an eclipse data set from the on code
a consortium we we also have this fairly
robust
so we then use these models to uh
examine this
curated data set of 37 exonic mutations
that cause
exon skipping and 45 exonic mutations
that do not cause skipping so
so they're known to be neutral and then
we looked
at with a 15 nucleotide input so the
variant in the
in the middle and then seven nucleotides
in each direction
we then looked at the change in score
from the wild type to the variant
and analyzed in the skipping
group versus the non-skipping and for a1
we see maybe a little
tendency to a an increase in the
skipping
uh group but not a statistically
significant and that's probably because
there's
many of these that are regulated by
multiple proteins so it might not
necessarily be a1 directly that is
causing the axon skipping
but for srs at one we do see a
significantly
uh decrease in score that is greater for
the skipping
uh mutation than for the non-skipping
and srsf1 is an sr protein and many sr
proteins have
fairly uh overlapping binding
affinity and can be uh can substitute
for each other
uh so this may be indicates that
both that srsf1 is often involved and so
that
a mutation that cause exon skip it might
be disrupting an srsf1 binding site
but also might indicate just in general
that the binding of sr proteins
is affected by these uh skipping
mutations and not so much for the
non-skipping
we can then combine them so it could be
an interaction so it's a combination of
both gaining a1 binding and losing sr1
so we take the change in the srs1 score
and then we subtract a1 the change in a1
score from that because a1 is is a
negative
factor and then we still have this uh
significant change or difference between
the non-skipping and skipping
and if we have this thresh if we apply a
threshold
in the combined score of of about minus
0.4
we can see that we have many more of the
skipping mutations that are below that
and just a single one in the
non-skipping so so applying these might
actually be a
allowing in some way to to handpick or
or at least prioritize mutations in
exons that
are more likely to also cause x on
skipping
of course that also depends on the axon
itself
we also tried to use a 75 nucleotide
input
and here you can see that we see some of
the same trends but
the range in scores is a lot smaller
uh when we combine them the the p value
is lower actually than either
in separately but it's still not at that
statistically significant level but we
still see that trend
so obviously the length of the input
affects these scores
and if we look at one of them the atp 7a
x120 mutation uh this is located in the
middle here so here we have the the
deep clip binding profiles where we have
the reference in black and the variant
in red
and we can see in the binding profile
that there is a clear
increase in a1 so this is with the a1
model
so there is a clear increase in the a1
binding uh predicted
by the binding profile but if we look at
the overall score it's going from
something close to zero to something
just a little bit higher than zero
so not something that has a dramatic uh
[Music]
change in in terms of absolute value but
this binding profile
has a lot of negative uh values if you
look in
in the y-axis that's why the context in
general might be
uh negative so the the pro
the model itself is trained to recognize
a1 clip sites
so so maybe this would be a poor clip
side it might
but it still might be an a1 binding site
according to the binding profile
and if we then just use the 15
nucleotide input
then we get um
a much we still get that same binding
profile pattern where the a
mutation increases the the uh binding
profile values
but we also get a more uh
dramatic change in the in the overall
prediction scores and these scores range
from zero to one
so here we have something that is uh
below the mean or below the midpoint of
0.5 to something that is above it
so of course these patterns will affect
other tools
that are looking for different motives
as well
but having this binding profile really
allows us to to sort of
even though we have very low score we
can still see the effect
of the of the mutation so
this was on sort of uh real endogenous
data
where we have known mutations that have
been known and shown
in humans to cause sex and skipping but
we also wanted to see
whether in vitro experiments could uh
could correlate with these deep clip
predictions
so we performed uh surface plasmon
resonance imaging
which is a technique where you have a
flow
a plate a gold-plated plate where
the oligos can be covalently attached
and then you have a
flow of proteins and depending on how
much they bind
we can measure that different difference
and we do that by shining a light
and then measuring the uh the angle of
dispersion so if there is some binding
to the oligo
there will be some dispersion that
there's no binding it will have a
different angle
and if there's a lot of binding it will
be even more different so so by
measuring this angle we can estimate or
quantitate how much is binding to these
oligos
so so the way that the experiment is run
is that you have your
oligos on on the uh on the on the plate
uh without any proteins then you start
injecting a solution with the
purified recombinant protein so there's
only this particular protein
and then you uh do that for a number
for a period of time and hopefully it
will reach steady state
and then you start washing away the
protein to dissociate so then you can
get
a fairly complicated modeling of the
kinetics of this protein binding
so in in this experiment again with
using the
atp 7a xm20 example here we use this 15
nucleotide
uh sequence as an oligo uh and then
measure
the amount of recombinant a1 binding
so here in the wild type we then have
these
uh different concentration of the
protein
in different runs so we run them in
duplicates and then we
model that in in a single model that
that accounts for differences in
concentration
and then we plot that on top we then
take the the maximum of that model here
on the
response curve and then compare that
in the in the variant and as you can see
here there is a greatly increased a1
binding to this oligo as predicted by
by the binding profiles of both the
short
sequence and also the long so if we do
that for a number of these
exotic mutations where we have both the
wild type and the variant
and do it for both a1 and srz1 we can
then compare the
deplete prediction scores with the with
the maximum of this model fit
and as you can see there is a very
linear and statistically significant
correlation
between deep clip prediction scores and
then the actual measured
amount of protein binding in this in
vitro setup so so these models that are
trained on this in vivo data they
they still have uh a good correlation
with in vitro
experiments we also used again the
minigene with our favorite
mini gene akm so um looking again on
this patient mutation at precision 362
where we have a t we then ordered new
mutations
surrounding that uh so with that for for
these three base pairs
we had every possible combination uh we
then uh transfected these mini genes and
uh and purified rna and made
performed igpcr and by agarose gel so we
can then visualize here on the gel
and also do a semi-quantitative
quantitation of of the
percent uh spliced in of the exponents
the inclusion levels
so you can see here that we have ranges
from almost 100 inclusion
to less than 10 inclusion in the patient
mutation so there's a good range of
scores
um so then we again produce deep clip
scores
uh of these mutations across this site
uh and measure and then compared to the
inclusion levels
and again here for the a1 we see again
confirming a1
h9p1 as a splicing inhibitor so the
higher the deep flip score
the lower the inclusion level whereas
for sf1 we see a positive correlation
and when we combine them we get perhaps
an even better correlation
uh than just for instance srsf1 alone
and we know already that that for this
exon it's often a combination of the two
if we just plot the amount of change
relative to the wild type
we can again and see that here in blue
we have the inclusion
change from wild type and in orange we
have
a one change and in green si sub one so
when we have a negative a1 score we have
a negative change from the bile type we
also have a positive
increase in in inclusion compared to the
wild type so so uh so these models
actually
work uh quite well both in these in vivo
meaning gene studies
and also in the in vitro studies uh in
in predicting
uh the type of change that you would see
given a certain mutation
as it happens there's another mutation
in the academ gene
uh this time it's located at position
plus seven
in the intron intron six just after exon
six
so here we've indicated exon 6 in this
light gray
box and here in red is the mutation so
that's
in an a to g and we thought that it
might be tdb-43
so we make this deep clip tdp-43 model
based on multiple sources of clip
experiments both eclipse iclip and and
part clip
and and got these binding motifs which
are uh
look very similar to to the already
known uh binding prefaces
preferences of tdp-43 so we then made
this
uh binding profile across this 75
nucleotide input here
and again we see that uh when the
binding profile
or when we have the mutation then the
binding profile predicts an increase in
in tp-43 so there is already a binding
site here
uh and then this binding side is
extended
uh according to d flip so
again we turn to a shorter
again we tend to a shorter um
oligonucleotide so we could use that
in an spri measurement so here we also
predict it
with deep clip and we see the same type
of binding profile here
that we have a predicted binding side
and then that binding size is enhanced
and then
elongated we can also use dip clip to
just plot the difference
uh to to the reference sequence so here
is just
uh the difference between the two curves
and that sometimes gives you a better
impression
of of the effect of the mutation and and
and which direction it's going so here
it's
it's it's very clear that imitation
causes increased finding
so so if we again take these two binding
profiles
and then do an spi measurement with
recombinant tdp-43
also called todd epp we can again see
that yes
we do have binding to the reference the
wild type sequence
but just as deeply predicted we have an
increase in binding
we then had again a minigene approach
where
we again ordered a mutation and
got so so we had both the wild type and
the varian
we then performed an sri experiment
where we knocked down the levels of
tdp-43
so here on the left you can see that
tdp-43 is knocked down significantly
and then we transfected these cells and
again performed
uh rc pcr and and measured uh inclusion
of the exon
with on an acrylic scale so here you can
see on the wild side there's no
difference between knock down and
non-knocked down tp-43 but in the mutant
uh when we don't knock down
uh tp-43 we have mostly skipping
of exon 6 and then when we knock down
tp-43 we have
mostly inclusion so this is demonstrate
that gev43
is actually involved in regulating this
safe this
uh this exon if you look at the binding
profile you can see that there's also
some motives that are
uh not affected or that don't really
look like the ugug motif of the
model but have a fairly high profile
and that's perhaps context indicating
okay so these this type of context
is is contributing positively so
we have actually something that is
contributing positively right downstream
of uh of the of the binding side uh
so the problem with this mutation is
that
uh there are approaches with using
antisense oligonucleotides
where you can produce a molecule that is
complementary so
sort of an artificial nucleotide or rna
that binds to the site uh where gtp 43
would bind
and then inhibits binding and then that
can remove the negative effect of tp43
but in this case the mutation is located
uh so close to the normal spice side
though that if we do that there is a
very high risk that we affect normal
spicing so that would not be very
therapeutically relevant but we have
this
binding uh curve going up immediately
downstream
so uh we designed these oligos
to cover that portion instead so we're
not
affecting we're not actually uh
overlapping with the mutation and most
of that
binding site but we are overlapping with
this region where we have
uh also a high binding profile
so if we perform an experiment where we
treat the cells with sso either a
control sso or one of these
sso1 or ss2 sso2 so splice switching
oligo we call them
we can see when we transact with the
control oligo on the wild side nothing
happens that's the same for the ss01 and
sso2
but in the mutant uh here we have the
control where we have predominant
skipping just as before
of the exon when we treat with either of
these sso
we get predominant inclusion so so it
seems like we are predict
we are affecting binding and we removing
the negative effect of tdp-43
so this is a case of where the binding
profile actually is
is fairly essential to actually
designing these therapeutics
which because this is an intronic
variation
the patient would when treated with
these oligos would produce a completely
normal function and a
functional enzyme and not have disease
so uh these because these binding
profiles they
they sort of uh also show patterns of
binding
uh and because tdp 43 is is this
known factor involved in in amiotrophic
lateral sclerosis
als where it's uh often observed to
either be mutated itself and causing
familial
als or it's depleted from the nucleus
and and sort of sequestered in the
cytoplasm and that way it's not able to
exert its normally from
normal function in the nucleus and gp43
is known to repress
pseudo exons so as i mentioned before
pseudo accidents are part of the introns
that are not supposed to normally be
included
and part of that is because they're
repressed by splicing inhibitors
and one of those might be tb-43 in some
cases
so uh losing tdp-43 in the new from the
nucleus
could activate pseudo excellence and be
a part of what drives the
als pathology so there's been a number
of studies so here's one by gin
colleagues
from 2017 where they were looking at
pseudoexons that are specifically
activated
either in muscle and neuron by
specifically knocking down tdp-43
so we took those pseudo-exons and then
we
produced binding profiles across them
and then we took out this region
50 nucleotides upstream and 50
nucleotides downstream of the axon
and then 50 nucleotides into the exon
for both the three prime and the five
point supply side
and then we produce this uh average uh
binding profile part here
and what's interesting is that you can
see that there is actually a difference
in
in how uh tdp 43 seems to bind
uh in muscle uh specific pseudo axons
versus the neuron specific
so in neurons it's an almost equal
distribution
upstream and downstream but in muscles
it's much more
likely to be binding to the downstream
region
or the end of the exon so so because als
is more affecting neurons than muscles
themselves this is important in
in looking at pseudoexcellence and which
ones might be particularly important in
neurons
we can also look uh we can also look at
the heat map here
uh and so this gives us for each of the
pseudo accents
the uh sort of the binding profile uh
instead of a
as a as a curve we're here we're
plotting out as a heat map with
with red as a high score and blue as a
very low score
so again here you can see that in the
neuron specific it's it's usually either
or
uh and in the muscles there's uh so so
in some of the neurons there's actually
very little
chance of tp-43 is very blue here in the
downstream region
whereas for the muscles it's uh it's
almost always a high
uh number of binding sites in the
downstream region
so so this is really an example of of
how
binding profiles can provide these
immediate
patterns of binding without performing
experiments
so just to summarize with with deep clip
we have
we have this architecture this uh
modeling of uh
a protein binding that that incorporates
arbitrary context
so it's not just the structure it's just
uh
different types of context that are uh
sort of for each model is specific to
that particular protein
uh depending on on the quality of
training data
of course if you have bad quality
training data
then models will also be comparatively
uh
worse we also have these individual base
scores
and as it turns out that actually
mitigates some of the biases that we see
in trading data
it also can inform this design of
therapeutics because you get much more
information
about what is affecting binding of this
protein
and we can use it to to analyze these
general patterns of binding
and because we have this binding profile
we also better able to predict
unvariable length input
as you saw this this length of input it
does affect the binding score
suppose you had only 10 nucleotides as
input that would be very different from
having 100 nucleotides as an input
if you go across and look at the entire
genome
and if you had or just a hundred
thousand base pair
then having a score between zero and one
becomes quite meaningless
uh but we can actually produce these
binding profiles
uh across one hundred thousand base
pairs and then use a sliding window
to identify possible binding sites and
we also make deep clip available as a
website
so so you can use the already trained
models
and then get figures uh like this like
i've shown you here with the binding
profiles
and you can input both wild type and
variant and get these different
parts where we have both the reference
and the variant on the same part
so it really makes it a lot easier for
biologists to analyze
if their mutations might be able to
affect protein binding
to that particular rna
so finally i just want to uh acknowledge
and thank you all of our funders
uh and uh all of the rest of the of the
people in the
rna spicing and disease group which is
headed by uh parker and andresen
and particularly alexander alex uh here
he's circled in red
uh alex uh and i designed deep flip and
alex implemented a lot of the
uh of the neural network architecture
and designed a lot of that
uh also siemens worked uh from uh jan
baumbach's group
uh who's now at uh in humboldt uh
working on
the deep clip website so and i just want
to thank you for your attention and
uh and i'm happy to uh to answer
questions
thank you thomas for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
could this solution be used for
sequencing alignment or sequencing
comparison for instance
okay so uh thank you for the question um
that's not
something that we've considered much uh
i suppose
in if you're looking at cross species
comparisons
and looking for uh for uh conservation
not so much of the sequence but of the
uh of the regulation so that could be
binding of
proteins to particular exons and
regulation that
might not be appear immediately
recognizable just from that sequence
alone
and then using these uh protein binding
models could give you some clues about
uh more functional conservation that
sequencing conservation
but we haven't really we haven't really
thought about using it for uh for
sequencing alignment
okay thank you thomas our next question
is
how long can my sequences be or how
short
yeah so so i've talked about this long
prediction mode and that's where we use
this sliding window algorithm
uh and and we trained uh all of these
models with a max
model maximum input size of 75
nucleotides
and a minimum size of 12 nucleotides so
so
in the range of that you will you will
get the single
you get the binding profile you will get
the single prediction score
uh but if you're using longer sequences
than that then you have to use this
sliding window window algorithm to
produce a binding profile
and that does not produce an overall
prediction scores because that becomes
less and less meaningful
you can actually use very short input
you can even use one nucleotide as an
input and that will
sometimes give you a surprising score
but of course it doesn't really make
sense so
so you still have to think about what
does does it make sense to use this type
of this
sequence input so so down to about 12
nucleotides is
is is okay uh probably but but
usually we use around 15 to 20
nucleotides uh because we want to use
also oligos uh to test them and then we
use uh
75 maybe for for a binding profile that
covers this
okay thank you thomas and we have
another question coming in
do you plan to develop new models when
clip data for other rbps will be
available
do you train your model only in human
data
yeah so thank you yes and and absolutely
so so right now we have about
195 different models uh on the website
and you can download the weights uh of
that and also use them locally
uh so we so we have a local uh
installation option for
for deep clip in addition to the website
and those cover
around 115 different proteins and and we
are producing more models and this as
they become available
uh so far we've only produced human
protein
but a lot of these factors are fairly
conserved so so you might
be able to get away with using them in
different species but we do find to also
produce models for
for other uh probably mostly model uh
organisms like uh like mouse and rat and
and things like that but uh but you can
always train your own models if you have
a specific uh
species that you're very interested in
and the data is available
and thomas which is better to use the
score or the binding profile
yeah so so in my talk i present a lot of
data that where we use this
overall score to correlate with with the
data the experimental data
but but uh in many cases the binding
profile will give you that extra bit of
information to actually as a biologist
uh evaluate okay so does this actually
seem to be affecting my protein so
source score is it's just it's such a
a decrease in the amount of information
that you get so so
when you do look at the data i think
it's always important to look at that
binding profile
but you can get away with with the sort
of prioritizing
in some cases just using the overall
score so
so so both have their their uh benefits
and
and uh negatives uh sort of uh
the binding profile is is more hands-on
and and
it's more difficult to rank if you have
a hundred different mutations it's more
difficult to rank them
just looking at binding profile then
then the overall voice
is good to use okay
fantastic thank you we've got time for a
few more questions
the next question is do you observe
large differences between models for the
same rbp
trained on eg par clip and eclip data
yeah so uh so thanks that's that is
something that we that we do observe and
that
that's uh something that is
sort of that we provide uh on the
website right now we have different
models
uh with just trained on on a single
source so it's either the pocket or the
e-clip
apart from that tdp-43 model where we
took a lot
of data and and if you look at them
there
quite a few of them are actually quite
different when you look at e-clip versus
parclip
and and then it's it's more of a
question of how biased is the model so
you get slightly different motives and
and different profiles so um
we are sort of planning to to hopefully
identify which models are the best
and which clip method might produce the
most consistent
the best performing models but so far we
we're providing the models as they are
and
allowing you to sort of use them and
then
make your own decisions but we do see
differences between
different clips sources
okay thank you thomas we have time for
one last question
can i compare the scores of different
models directly
yeah so so because they're trained
independently of each other they
their predictions are not like
one-to-one so you can't really compare
them
but on the other hand we do allow you to
to run
multiple models on the same input same
at the same time on the website
so you do actually have that option of
having a single mutation that where
you're comparing wild type and variant
and then comparing those
immediately so you can sort of look at
the binding profiles and see whether
they're going up and down
but in terms of comparing absolute
change in in a numeric value they're not
directly comparable
but it's absolutely uh possible to look
at binding profiles and score and see
okay so is it going upward down
in these two different proteins
thank you thomas do you have any final
comments for our audience today
i just want to thank you all for
attending and i also want to uh
to thank gene gentrip for uh for
sponsoring this talk
and lab roots for assisting it's been
very uh very uh
nice working with you uh and and having
this opportunity
to present this work and i hope you uh
who attended the talk uh
will try out the clip and and uh and
give us some feedback and i'm also
available
for for questions via email if you have
further questions
so thank you thank you again thomas for
your time today and for your important
research
we would like also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor jen script for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye